- There was a guy playing
here at the Sip 'n Dip
and he decided he wanted to
go on a vacation, so he came
and asked me if I would
play his two-week vacation,
and his two-week vacation
ended and he didn't come back.
He blew town.
And I've been here ever since,
for 56 years.
Oh, I love Montana.
They come from all over the world,
and they say that they
don't know of a state
where people are any friendlier.
They're strangers when
they walk into the bar.
Before they know it, everybody's
talking to everybody else
and visiting, and they
haven't even known each other,
you know, but...
I play everything.
I'm an Elvis freak,
and people have a fetish for Johnny Cash,
and so I do two, three from him.
But nothing new lately,
because my eyes have gone bad
and I can't read my music anymore,
so mostly from memory.
The old boy up above,
he's been good to me,
giving me my health and
letting these fingers work,
that I, you know, didn't get arthritis.
When I started, I worked
six nights a week.
The guy that built it,
he went all over,
to islands, and got all
kinds of statues and stuff
and that's why the lounge is what it is.
How it got popular, we don't know.
They're trying to make a
celebrity out of me at my age.
God, I walk in a store and
then some guy will recognize,
"There's Piano Pat," you know.
I have to have my picture
taken with them all.
You know. It goes on, and on, and on.
I don't know how real movie stars do it,
because it's a drag.
It is.
If it happened when I was
younger, eh, you know,
but, it's just what can happen in life.
You don't know.
- So 10?
- 10. There's 10 merpeople.
- Yes.
- So we have 10 merpeople.
- [Belle] My day job is,
I'm a LPN at the local hospital.
My friends are always the ones
that are saying, "She's a mermaid."
- [Saoirse] Mm-hmm.
- [Belle] And I'm like,
"Okay, let me get my phone out
and show you the photos,"
'cause they're like,
"No you're not." Like,
"I don't believe you."
- [Saoirse] Yeah. Yeah, I
work at the university here in
Great Falls. I'm the assistant registrar,
so at our commencement, there
was a family from out of
of town discussing, like,
this place where you can go see mermaids.
And so my boss snuck in
and was like, "We have
our very own mermaid,"
and they're like, "Oh my god!"
And I'm just like, "Hi, yeah."
- [Belle] Makes you more unique.
- [Saoirse] Mm-hmm.
- [Belle] Makes things go quicker.
- [Saoirse] Yeah, my husband's in the Army
and he lives in Texas,
so I got a nine-month
deployment to get through,
and you had a six-month?
- [Belle] Yes, uh, this kinda
just fills the extra void
when they're gone, and lets you get out
of your shell a little bit.
[Saoirse] Mm-hmm.
When I swim, I feel more beautiful.
Putting on the wig and the lipstick,
and the tail, you know, just kinda,
you get to be someone that you aren't.
- [Saoirse] When you get the
compliments people telling you,
"You look so graceful, it's
so natural, it's so pretty,"
it's nice and it's kinda humbling
that you can do something
that, you know, not a lot of
people can, and you didn't
really know you could do
until you started this job.
- [Pat] I had a kid in his
twenties not too long ago
and he says, "Well who's
going to play when you,
you..." You know, I
mean, he can see I'm 84.
He says, "Well, you better
start teaching somebody.
You better give them lessons."